hey guys welcome back to awesome builds
I know it's been a while and I'm sorry
about that but I appreciate your
patience I haven't been taking a
vacation or anything like that
necessarily I've just been really busy
with some other projects as you can see
and I'm looking forward to sharing with
you guys as we get closer and closer
I'll probably be posting some more stuff
on my Facebook page some little snippets
behind the scenes and stuff like that
and I will be covering some of the stuff
on some future episodes of awesome build
but however because there is so much
kind of going on so much to do I won't
be able to post episodes every week
you'll probably more like every other
week for the time being until I can get
past this major project and some other
projects that are going on so I do
apologize for that I would love to do
the show every week but with everything
else that's going on I have to kind of
just keep the workflow going so let's
just go right into it hope you guys
enjoy
[Music]
so today we're gonna be covering tools
of the trade or at least the tools that
you kind of need to start out with and
these are mostly the tools that I used
when I started making props I fed a lot
of people ask me what kind of tools I
use or what kind of tools are good to
start out with if they want to start
making props or costumes or that kind of
thing for me these are kind of like the
core tools that I use when I first
started making props and they're pretty
basic and some of these a lot of these
you'll probably already have like in
your garage or at home or whatever but
and they're all pretty easy to obtain
so all these tools aren't super
expensive they're not gonna break the
bank and if you're serious about making
props then these are the basic core
tools they should probably start out
with so safety first if you haven't
already go out and get some safety
goggles or some kind of safety glasses
or any kind of goggles you know that you
can see clearly and they're gonna
protect your eyes another very important
one because gonna be doing a lot of
painting or using different chemicals is
respirator you know it's not super
expensive you're probably about thirty
bucks maybe for a decent respirator and
some filters and again I highly
recommend it guys if you're gonna be
doing anything that has any kind of
you're gonna be giving off any kind of
fumes or anything like that you know
take care of yourselves it's really
worth it and then I would also just buy
a package of these disposable masks that
you can wear for any time you're gonna
be doing any sanding or anything like
that you know you can use the respirator
but it's great to have them give other
people working in the shop and stuff
like that you're gonna be doing a lot of
sanding you don't want to be breathing
in any of that dust the sawdust or
plastic dust or phone dust or anything
like that and when you're working always
make sure that you're working in a
well-ventilated area right make sense
you want to take Gary hands right so so
nice work gloves come in handy I've got
a variety of different pairs really
doesn't matter you can get a pair of
decent work gloves for three or four
bucks probably and up you know you don't
need to spend a ton of money you can
just get a pair of decent work gloves
are going to
to protect your hands also some vinyl or
latex gloves to protect your hands when
you're mixing any kind of chemicals or
using different kind of adhesives or
paint or whatever you know protect
yourselves so we'll start off with some
of the most basic and probably these
tools that you have lying around your
house we'll just start with different
rulers it's different straight edges a
t-square is great to have just a ruler I
recommend an architect's ruler it really
comes in handy and tried-and-true just a
tape measure another invaluable and very
inexpensive thing you'll need our clamps
now you can get these pretty cheap you
can usually buy a decent clamp for about
a buck or you can buy usually a kit or a
set of different clamps or something
like that for about twenty or
twenty-five bucks I think I got a set of
four or five and good I would get it I
would get a variety two of different
sizes and stuff like that and again
you're gonna use them all the time so
invest in some in some clamps tape
you're gonna use masking tape our
painters tape duct tape electrical tape
you're gonna need a variety of different
kind of tape for either marking things
off or holding things in place it's just
going to come in handy you're gonna use
it all the time a favorites is the
metallic tape this stuff is you can
probably find at your hardware store
it's gonna be in the area for duct work
and stuff like that and I use it all the
time for a variety of different
applications and it really comes in
handy you'll need things that cut with
like scissors or some hobby shears now
these I've had for PAL about 15 years
they're great because I can cut leather
I can cut thin aluminum and they're
pretty rigid and they really have held
up and for me they've lasted the test of
time and of course an exacto knife an
exacto knife or any kind of utility
knife so you have all kinds of utility
knives
this is an invaluable tool you're going
to use it all the time it's great for
cutting foam and keep again keep your
blade sharp or keep extra blades on hand
I always want to use a really sharp
blade you don't want to mess around with
a dull blade and screw up a cot or
anything like that so keep your blade
sharp or replace them frequently
of course other retractable knives and
then of course just things to write with
you need a pencil to make mark a sharpie
it great yeah I will probably even
invest in just getting one of these
little hobby kits you can do they come
in different variations and stuff like
that but this one I bought probably
about seven or eight years ago use it
all the time it's got a variety of
different types of blades saws carving
tools a plain sanding block little
measuring tape calipers there's a great
value I think it was like 25 or 30 bucks
and it's got a variety of stuff in here
that I use all the time and I saw of
some kind just a handsaw will do but if
you have power tools whatever that's
great but for years I got by with just
an saw hot glue gun hot glue gun again
is a staple you're gonna need it and
you're gonna use it almost every day if
you're building props or making costumes
or anything like that it doesn't have to
be you know this is a nicer ones at the
wall but for years I used really cheap
you know hot glue guns you can get it a
hobby store or Michaels or something
like that
you're gonna need needlenose pliers and
some wire cutters or snips hammer
screwdrivers pliers or some kind of vise
grips
kind of like something like that files I
would get a set of files they they
really do come in handy you're getting
to use them quite a bit
sandpaper I would get a variety of
different grits sandpaper
Emery cloth you can usually buy a packet
or like a variety pack or something like
that
sanding sponges I use all the time
sanding blocks some kind of sandpaper is
something you're gonna be doing a lot of
sanding
you're gonna be making props and one of
the main tools that's sort of when I
really started making props the one that
I became invaluable that I really use
all the time on almost every project
would be a dremel now you don't have to
get a super super expensive one when I
started off I just had it was pretty
simple it was actually a battery-powered
dremel and it did the job fine for a
little while eventually I needed
something that was a little bit heavier
duty but you can definitely start off
with a cheaper version you know just to
kind of get used to it
and get used to the different bits and
stuff and the different applications but
again I use this all the time for
grinding sanding cutting buffing there's
gonna be such an array of things that
you're gonna use it for you're gonna
wonder how you ever get along without it
so definitely you invest and you know I
just have to be a super expensive one
but invest in a decent rotary tool and
again usually can find like a variety
kit of different bits and stuff like
that this one's got 200 pieces of
grinders Sanders cutting wheels and all
kinds of stuff again it's got some
replacement bits and stuff I think it
says you know $120 value again I think
it was like at Home Depot for like 30
bucks or something or 35 bucks so well
worth the investment
another very early tool that I and this
is probably my second or third one is a
heat gun you're gonna be using a heat
gun quite a bit especially if you're
going to be doing any kind of work with
a VA phone or anything like that
now you're gonna be using the heat gun
quite a bit I would get one with you
know that a temperature setting if
you're gonna be spending the money to
get one I would go ahead and get a
pretty decent one that's gonna last you
and of course a power drill I'm gonna be
using this all the time doesn't have to
be a berry pack it could be courted
but you're gonna need a drill of some
kind
so definitely invest in that all right
well last but not least the most
important tool in my array and very
often the first tool to get me started
confident thanks a lot guys for tuning
in and sorry again for the long lapse in
episodes as I said I was quite busy but
we're gonna get things kind of back on
track I've got a lot of new projects
coming up and can't wait to show them to
you guys and of course very soon we will
be doing the studio tour so watch out
for that once again these are the basic
tools these are the things these are not
the only tools you are going to use as
you guys have seen I have a ton of tools
it's taken me years to kind of
accumulate I will probably do another
episode in the future where I do a tour
of the workshop where I'll kind of go
over some of the more I guess advanced
tools that I have and use but most of
them are exist to make things a little
bit easier or faster you can still build
most of the things that you're going to
need to build with these basic tools and
as I said for years and years these are
the basic tools that I used to build
stuff I didn't have a lot of the space
or didn't have a lot of the room or I
just didn't have the money so you can
definitely make do with these tools to
get started I hope this helps you guys
out and don't forget to check me out on
Facebook and James Jim J res if you guys
have any more questions or anything like
it you can drop me a line there also for
any of you guys who live in the
Chicagoland area on March 3rd 4th and
5th Columbia College is having columbic
on and
it's been going on for a few years I
think but channel awesome is going to be
the guests there so Rob and Doug and
Malcolm and Tamara and myself will be
there I will be hosting a panel on March
5th called just build it a prop makers
guide to cheap props and basically I'll
just be talking about a lot of the stuff
that we cover here on the show but
you'll be able to see me in person and
I'm gonna have some of the props with me
and stuff like that some props that
we've made in the past to kind of show
off and answer questions and things like
that so if you guys are in the
Chicagoland area and you want to check
it out I think it's only like five bucks
a person or something like that for a
day so yeah swing by and check it out
say hi all right thanks a lot guys
I'll see you next time
[Music]